pues lo cierto Es que fontan más allá de
esos 13 míticos goles en ese mundial del
58 es un poco como lo dijo Emmanuel Mako
en su twit es el mito fundacional de el
fútbol francés junto a copa y también de
hecho a junto a Roger Epi Anthony que
son los tres grandes jugadores de esa
gesta del 58 en ese equipo de Francia
que le devolvió de hecho la esperanza la
hinchada francesa Francia había salido
eliminada en la primera ronda en el
mundial del 54 apenas unos cientos de
hinchas habían ido a Suecia a ver al
equipo en el 58 y finalmente en su
regreso aquí a Francia pues fueron
aclamados fue toda una gloria y por
supuesto pues Tuvo una muy linda carrera
pero muy breve carrera como jugadora de
fútbol aquí en Niza con quien ganó copa
de Francia campeonato y luego sobre todo
con el
equipo del cual pues es el ídolo y ese
el jugador más emblemático 122
anotaciones en seis temporadas pero como
les decía él pues Tuvo una carrera
bastante corta tuvo que ponerle fin a
los 28 años una doble fractura de su
pierna izquierda y justamente en el
momento en que él iba a ir a jugar
contra con el español de Barcelona luego
ya pues se convertiría en entrenador
breve entrenador del equipo de Francia
en tan solo dos ocasiones y luego sería
del París San